she's inside me and she's angry your
friend she's a meta and not one of the
friendly ones just sick she's I'm
thinking straight she is a bloody menace
knock her out Caitlin what are you doing
I'm not gonna fight you
you keep messing with everyone's life
flash all of this Tuesday at 8/7 central
on the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie so new flash
footage let's break it down they're
finally doing killer frost I really wish
they would have called the episode the
Winter Soldier but they would have been
sued out of existence by Marvel so you
can kind of see what they're doing here
it's kind of like a version of Captain
America's Civil War where Caitlin is the
Winter Soldier
you can even transpose dialogue from the
Civil War trailer on to this he's my
friend
so was I sorry Tony were like the flash
goes broke and punches Julianne when he
orders him to take Caitlin down so it's
not quite a hundred percent it have to
be Cisco that the flash were punching if
it were really Captain America Civil War
but that's basically what they're going
for
Caitlin goes rogue the teen tries to
save her but the question is is like
what pushes her over the edge and why is
it that she's going evil like Cisco got
powers and even though you know he's
maybe a little emotionally repressed
he's not evil like he just uses his
powers whenever he needs to so what is
it that's happening inside Caitlin's
mind that this other killer frost
personality is slowly taking over
they might explain that in the next
couple of episodes like as they kind of
build her killer frost persona out this
year like she's different from the
previous killer frost that we've seen
before but in the trailer she says she's
inside me she's really angry so what I
think is is that killer frost is just
like all this repressed anger that
Caitlin has and it's just slowly
manifesting in this way but she doesn't
actually have legit split personalities
so hopefully they'll explain that a
little bit better either in this episode
or after the mid-season finale but you
can kind of see like the basic art is
that Caitlin is out trying to help on a
case and something happens to just like
make her snap while she's working with
Julianne she freezes his arm then she
confronts him later like I'm a meta like
how dare you hate metas so we all know
that he's kind of prejudiced against
them now or at least he hates the ones
that he thinks are misusing their powers
so that probably doesn't help that he's
bad-mouthing metas in front of Caitlin
so you can see her here showing her
powers off but now you know Captain
America Civil War twist Barry punches
Julianne to save Caitlin now he become
a fugitive meaning that Jo another
detective at the police station will
have to go after the flash unless
there's some big twist the team flash is
able to pull off so depending on how
they handle things Julian might be going
after team flash after this episode so
this gonna be really interesting for
Barry and Julian scenes after this
because Julian will be like will the
Flash's a criminal we have to go after
him but Barry will still have to work at
the police station with him and then you
wonder what's gonna happen when Julian
finds out that Barry is the flash he'll
hate him even more for lying to him this
whole time Plus Barry will kind of be a
criminal so if you remember back during
season one when we got the teaser for
killer frost as Barry was going back the
first time to save his mother
we saw Barry sitting in prison that
might be what this is that might be how
Barry ends up in iron Heights prison but
let me know as you guys think of this
very Captain America Winter Soldier type
twist for Caitlin I do like what it
means for the dynamic of the group it
definitely creates a lot of drama in an
interesting way like it's not super
soapy like she just completely loses her
and they're like oh my god how are
we gonna save our friend here I think
they've done a lot better job servicing
at least Caitlin's Ark I mean there's a
lot of other characters that they have
to get to like you can see they're doing
stuff with Joe they're kind of trying to
do something interesting with Barry and
iris but Caitlin's Ark now doesn't have
anything to do with her relationship
status or the fact that she's a woman so
that is one of the reasons why I'm most
excited for her story I mean in addition
to the fact that she's a really cool
comic book character in the costume from
last night like I've already kind of
talked a little bit about her future
costume that's from a potential future
the not so distant future so it's not
like years and years away based on
what's happening right now obviously
they're gonna try and change the future
but this is actually a better look at it
like they color tuned it so it was like
all blue you couldn't really see it that
well this is what it looks like in broad
daylight
so as Caitlin heavy as these last couple
of episodes have been you can expect in
future seasons for them to do this with
the other characters too like the other
side characters so the really cool thing
is that we're not even at the mid-season
finale so they have like the whole back
half of the season to
with more killer froth stuff this is
really just the beginning like even
though it's been seven episodes they're
just getting started with some of the
big stuff we just met savat are we're
just meeting killer frost we don't even
know who dr. alchemy is yet although I
think most of us have a pretty solid
theory but dr. alchemy will be unmasked
so to speak in the mid-season finale so
you don't have to wait a couple more
weeks to find out what's going on with
that but the DC giveaway is still going
on all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's a $20 Amazon gift card there
is a new episode of arrow tonight that
I'll post they're introducing a huge
comic book character it's like a mega
twist that's right out of the comics so
make sure you watch it while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for my flash episode 6 Easter eggs and
you can click here for the trailer for
the big 4 night crossover thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight